je suis ravi de souhaiter la bienvenue à
lui qui est entré vétéran de la
politique
extérieure de russie c'est un plaisir
que monsieur lavrov et des nôtres
aujourd'hui et
nous avons beaucoup plus de sujets à
discuter aujourd'hui
ce qui
rend cette opportunité plus importante
mais sur la prof vous avez la parole
chers collègues chers amis merci de
m'avoir invité
les créateurs de se faire remonter vite
et a parlé aujourd'hui
je suis ravi de voir beaucoup de jeunes
ici dans cette salle ça faire un vrai
plaisir
mais l'essentiel est que les jeunes
soient présents au présidium aussi et
pas seulement dans la salle
donc nous partageons les mêmes idées et
l'essentiel c'est d'être à l'heure avec
le avec la modernité et compris la vie
internationale et ce qui se passe
actuellement sur la scène internationale
je ne vais pas m'y arrêter en détail
nous allons j'en ai déjà parlé beaucoup
j'ai publié bon beaucoup d'articles
consacrés à ces sujets
et les tapes que nous traversons
aujourd'hui
signifie le passage à la multipolarité
ce sera une longue période
et bien évidemment
le modèle occidental
centré sur les états unis vers un monde
plus démocratique plus stable
cette période sera longue
mais nous voyons que le centre de la vie
internationale s'est déjà déplacé de
l'europe sic vers d'autres parties du
monde vers le résident je pense que
c'est évident pour tous et je pense que
la vie internationale de liens plus
inclusive en ce qui concerne
les différents facteurs les modèles du
développement
les les traditions politiques les
traditions de
civilisation et de culture donc il faut
y penser
mais il est assez clair que
l'équilibré traditionnel des forces
n'est plus à même de résoudre les
problèmes qui existent il faut
rechercher un équilibre et d'intérêt
monsieur le cas nos fans a parlé
récemment dans un de ses articles
lorsqu'on arrive à négocier
est les
solutions consensuelles
seront toujours beaucoup plus stable par
rapport à ce qui se fait à huis clos est
ensuite proposée aux presque du monde
comme vérité en dernière instance
c'est ce qui se passe actuellement avec
le concept occidental du l'entrée
mondial basé sur
les règles
cette idée qui circule dans les milieux
politiques
mais
après le coup d'état en ukraine
et la réunion de l'écrit b avec la
russie
réunification de la crimée
et donc
l'occident après a fait de ce concept
une doctrine pour l'union européenne et
pour le temps donc il s'agit de l'offre
mondiale basé sur les règles pour
développer ces initiatives l'occident a
proposé beaucoup de formats comme par
exemple l'alliance des multilatéraliste
qui réunit l'allemagne et la france
puis la lutte contre l impunité pour
l'utilisation des armes chimiques
partenariat global
pour respecter le droit international
humanitaire
tout cela
concerne les sujets discutés au sein des
nations unies
et mais nous voyons des tentatives de
discuter à huis clos
sans tenir compte
de la position des états membres des
nations unies
et l'occident a tendance à présenter
cela comme des ultimatums
ils agissent tout simplement
unilatéralement
un autre
tendance en vogue ce sont les
c'est le quad
l'inde l'australie les états unis le
japon et la création du bloc au cuss
ce qui nuit à l'ats
l'existence des formats traditionnels
universel en fait c
c'est déjà
été le cas de l'océan il y avait en
feront main nue c'est que été la réunion
de laisser en ac en plus
tous ces formats s'appuyer sur le
principe du consensus
et sur le principe du pied d'égalité
et compris la chine le japon la russie
tous les pays clefs
mais ce concept de l'indochine dieu
pacifique qui vise à détruire le système
s'appuyant sur
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité pour
tous
donc ce sont les règles que nous voyons
ici aussi
et les états unis vont convoi qu'ils
feront pour la démocratie au mois de
décembre c'est tout à fait clair qu'il
s'agit d'une initiative américaine et ce
sont les américains que mon définir le
cercle des participants
donc ce serait intéressant sur le plan
sportif de voir
ce qu'ils vont participer
notamment les partenaires clef
des etats-unis au proche-orient qui sont
difficilement considérer comme des
démocraties mais bon on verra
et et notre exemple c'est
la convocation par président biden du
sommet sur la cyber sécurité
mais nous avons déjà aux nations unies
en forum sur la cybersécurité
nous en parlions déjà depuis 20 ans
et au début de cette année nous avons
concerté une résolution
sur
[Musique]
les cinq ans à venir qui définissent les
règles de fonctionnement d'un groupe de
travail ouvert à tous les
pays membres des nations unies et donc
c'est une occasion de discuter de tous
les problèmes qui existent dans ce
domaine donc cette
tendance 30e les soeurs malheureusement
maintenant elle se trouve dans son
apogée
nous voyons de cette situation est que
les relations internationales deviennent
de plus en plus complexes à plusieurs
niveaux
et il faut avoir une expertise de la
part des experts
nous
suivons de près les travaux du conseil
de politique extérieure et de défense
des autres fines tanks
et nous analysons non seulement la
situation sur la scène internationale
mais aussi
la
politique extérieure d'oeuvre et pays il
ya beaucoup d'idées très intéressantes
dont nous tenons compte
lorsque nous essayons de perfectionner
notre politique extérieure d'élaborer
les documents officiels et nous sommes
également reconnaissants pour tous les
pôles et toutes les critiques qu'ils
sont et danser à notre sujet
et bien sûr nous prenons cette critique
comme un exemple
de travail
conjoint
parfois on ne reproche
le manque d'idéologie des politiques
extérieures à la différence de ce que
fait l'occident
mais moi j'ai ma propre position là
dessus je pense que non seulement
l'expérience soviétique et l'expérience
mondiale
signifie que le messianisme
n'est pas une façon efficace de résoudre
les problèmes de la politique mondiale
et l'expérience soviétique
nous a poussé à faire de bonnes
conclusions
et là
la tâche principale notre politique
extérieure et de créer les bonnes
conditions pour le développement de la
russie
notamment à l'intérieur du pays
à la différence des états unis nous
n'avons pas de
prédilection idéologique ou tabous
idéologiques à l'égard de nos
partenaires étrangers mais
c'est plutôt notre avantage un avantage
pratique qui nous permet
de jouer un rôle actif pour résoudre les
conflits
qui reste au jour dans notre agenda nous
avons des relations avec tous les
parties prenantes
qu'il s'agisse des états ou
[Musique]
des ennuis d'agonistes à l'intérieur des
pays en conflit
et nous défendons toujours le droit
international et j'ai déjà cité
monsieur loukianov maintenant je vais
citer notre collègue qui dit jour que la
vérité est dans
dans nos rangs
c'est ça la clé principale des
politiques intérieures nous sommes
partis du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies nos participants à tous
les mécanismes de gestion globale
qu'il s'agit de l'asie de l'eurasie de
l'europe
et nous sommes partis à d'autres
institutions internationales qui sont
responsables pour
définir les tendances
du développement mondial comme le la
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai comme brics et
les travaux des institutions montre de
l'importance du travail qu'ils font
notre relation avec la chine l'inde
qui vise à renforcer le leadership
collectif
je parle aussi du sommet des cinq
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité donc je pense que
notre potentiel politique et stratégique
ce s'appuiera sur un agenda positif
en tenant compte
du monde multipolaire dans l'essentiel
c'est de revenir à ce qui est déjà
définis par la charte des nations
charte des nations unies ne sont pas
contre les règles comme tel si vous
voulez la charte des nations-unies déjà
un set de règles universelles et qui
sont acceptables pour tous
donc j'ai proposé un hashtag
nos règles la charte une des nations
unies je pense que ceci reflète
parfaitement bien le sens de nos efforts
internationaux et en conclusion je
voudrais encore une fois route
tournée
repenser de politique extérieure de
défense
nous sommes intéressés à maintenir un
dialogue permanent c'est très important
que
le conseil
analyse
non seulement les recherches et
biologiques occidentales
mais aussi
formule d'une façon tout à fait
autonomes les
les évaluations globales
sur les sujets qui intéressent notre
pays
donc
je resterai continuer à
travailler avec vous et je prie tous les
journalistes à quitter la salle de nos
discussions